i want to talk about this amazing
transformation that you've gone through
to become
chad oh okay chad is a 14 year old boy
yes and it's so funny because if i
didn't know you as the comedic performer
actor that you are and just saw you
i would think this is a very attractive
woman she cannot become a 14 year old
boy it's not going to happen
and i have to say this is
you have yes this is stunning
[Laughter]
i don't know if i should congratulate
you or what but you really have become
chad i really can disappear into looking
like a little dude with the right hair
and makeup
hollywood magic man all right well i
just wanted to show you now now chad
has obviously as a lot of 14 year old
boys do
trouble integrating in the world
anxieties and i'm just going to say this
is a side by side of me at 14.
i think we would have gotten along very
very well
oh my god that's so good we're we're
both like just a little dead behind the
eyes
yes yeah i never lost that deadness
behind the eyes
we just look like we've been through so
much at this point
don't you see us sitting together in the
cafeteria
uh at school and like eating mac and
cheese together and no one is talking to
us
yes like you know when a horse's spirit
is broken that's what we look like
oh i know what a horse's spirit looks
like when it's broken it's
my writers look like that we just you
turned out great so maybe there's hope
for chad yes
yeah you know it's funny because i'm
curious have you had the experience of
walking around as chad i i bring this up
because
the few there have been a few times in
my life when i've been made up for a
sketch
and i had the opportunity to walk around
once i was dressed as a policeman and
it's kind of dangerous to do
because you know but i i remembered
walking around
as a policeman and really kind of just
pretending trying to
like channel what's it like to be a
policeman of course you know i had a toy
gun and a tin badge but it was kind of
fun
to inhabit that in the real world what
about you have you walked around this
chat
um i have not so much for fun more out
of necessity like
you know when you're shooting you're so
busy doing that if i had like an hour
off i would be like oh i should just pop
into a grocery store and get that done
so there were a couple times where i was
just like
inside a ralph's with a shopping cart
fully dressed as chad
and was met with legitimate confusion
especially people were far enough to not
know it was a woman
you know dressed as a little boy they
were just like why is this small child
buying so much produce or like they
would just catch i'd be in like a full
kpop outfit like
testing the ripeness of avocados like
just no one understood what was going on
yeah i would think and it's yeah it's
probably something they don't associate
a 14 year old boy is not going to be
doing that very mature
too you know if you're if you're buying
any kind of hairspray or anything
yeah feminine products feminine products
i don't know what those are but i'm told
we have a clip here from chad and uh
i believe this is where you're getting
what looks to be a pretty amazing
pair of sneakers correct anything you
want to add to that or
my real father is in this scene oh
that's right i think he yeah
he fist bumps you he does look for that
the one the guy who just bumps you is
your real
father's acting debut let me let's let's
take a look at the clip and then i want
to ask you about that okay all right
here's a clip from chad
[Music]
artiste
[Applause]
what do we do now we are gonna watch
your goddamn life
[Music]
lamb talk you know what i'm gonna say
this
he's not bad and that look he gives to
camera on his line
it's almost like he's a little too into
it we didn't tell him he was going to
have a line because i didn't want him to
get nervous
and we did about 30 takes and he finally
nailed it
and now i'm worried he has the acting
bug and
is going to pursue this professionally
yeah
well step one is does he have a head
shot when your father gets a head shot
there's a lot of on onset stills of my
father that day but he's
i really he's been acting like asking me
about what it would take to join the
union now like i'm so nervous he's going
to get a publicist
and really just go rogue with this but
even on set like
he was amazing but he's not a trained
actor so
i was just nervous he was going to
wander into frame eating a bagel at any
given moment
also i just in the background and look
no sense look at the camera the way like
a horse sometimes does
and just like give a little wink
i love my my brothers and sisters and my
mother and father but
god i've just the idea of being in a
production
like with my dad any kind of
show business moment with my dad or mom
just two intersecting
yeah i always thought it's like
ghostbusters you can't cross those
you can't cross those streams you've got
to keep them separate yeah a monster is
created
yeah we survived it we survived it and
he's he's great
um and now i think he wants to do this
for a living which i'm horrified by
yeah i saw him just driving around in a
cherry red hummer
license plate star for life you're like
no leaning into it so hard